the falcons posted a video yesterday
from their draft room and in the video
that they posted
general manager terry fontenot took a
call from the lions while the falcons
were on the clock
right font no and the caller presumably
lions gm brad holmes had a short
conversation which fontenot says unless
he's calling with a much better deal
than he'd offered in their previous
discussions
the falcons are going to stay put and
take florida tight end
kyle pitts so the lions were trying to
make a move
the lions were trying to get to number
four and
you know chris the obvious reaction is
they wanted kyle pitts but
i think when we when we fold in the brad
holmes reaction uh-huh
to getting penne sewell at seven
it it helps to better understand his
excitement
because he was going to give up assets
to get him at four i think that's the
right interpretation
i i agreed i think that's why he had a
little giggle even with us the other day
talking to us because he was like we got
a guy that we just didn't think there
was any chance we were gonna get at
seven
you know and and yeah i'm with you mike
i think
that trade would have been totally for
penne sewell
again this look look at him in look at
how he's reacted
they're so excited i mean he had to have
been maybe the number one number two
player on their board but this is how
they want to build their team
so i think penne sewell was a guy they
were looking to trade to get to number
four for like you're saying
they have tj hawkinson he was the number
nine pick in the draft just two years
ago
they didn't need another top 10 tight
end to go along with it
so from that standpoint that's where
it's awesome and mike
honestly even with the video being
released i feel like that was part of
why they released it
a little to be like look you know like
look we were trying to trade
and we still got the guy we wanted at
seven it was awesome day like but the
falcons released it
oh i was wrong then i was wrong sorry
okay
that doesn't work as good okay sorry i'm
wrong on that one and
you you gotta wonder what the falcons
wanted because
right it it took a first round pick to
go from 12
to six when the eagles and the dolphins
did that deal eagles had the sixth pick
dolphins had the 12th that was a first
rounder to do that flip-flop
it was two extra first rounders and a
three to go from 12 to three
and peter king made this point before
the draft that maybe one of the reasons
we won't see as many drafts in the top
ten or trades excuse me in the top 10 is
because
the 49ers gave up so much to move from
12 to 3. yeah it it results in a higher
price
being applied to other trades i mean
you know and and you got the lions with
extra first-round picks because of the
matthew stafford trade in 2022 and 2023
maybe the falcons were
demanding a first-round pick for that
for that
trade and if they did want sewell and
they avoided giving up a first round
pick to get sewell yeah that's
reason to pound on the table if you're
brad holmes definitely definitely
like should be excited about that you
know if that's the guy that you had your
your you know your ion or the bull zion
all along and you end up getting them
that's amazing and listen i don't mean
yes i think your point about the 49ers
or what peter said i mean it's very real
i've heard that
that affected the market as far as what
was expected to trade up and things like
that
but also i think atlanta looked at it as
we've heard from a lot of people i mean
kyle pitts was
top two top three player on a lot of
people's board
and i think within what they're trying
to do right with arthur smith and become
a little bit of that tennessee titans
offense and run the ball and
have a joe new smith and play action
pass and those type of things
like he really fits you know like pene
sewell fits the culture of what the
lions want to do
the same thing for kyle pitts and the
falcons i think he's a special player
that also fits kind of how they're
trying to build their team and what
they're trying to do on the offensive
side of the ball so
i can understand them not wanting to
trade out unless they really got
you know something that really blew
their doors off
yeah uh i agree with you completely and
uh it's just neat
to understand a little bit more about
what was going on when brad holmes was
excited as he was now now chris one
angle that we haven't discussed
what if they were trying to get up there
to cut the line to get jamar chase
all right because they do need receivers
sure i know i i mean
that that definitely could be a
possibility you're you're right
i mean i i don't have an answer for you
there
uh i just have a feeling just with those
coaches
dan campbell like we've talked about
that this would be more their cup of tea
this kind of guy they're gonna win games
at the line of scrimmage that's kind of
the dna of all these coaches
the people in the front office
everything that way so
you know again jamar chase certainly
would have helped but i don't think they
look at it
as a valuable as position as they do a
franchise left tackle
yeah i i agree with you completely and
again
the the best evidence that that it was
sewell
is the brad holmes reaction because they
were in and of itself it's like man why
are you so excited i mean everybody
thought sewell was gonna fall to seven
anyway well yeah well when you're when
you're in the middle of it you're a
little more nervous because you're
thinking
maybe the falcons are gonna take him
maybe maybe the the
bengals are gonna take him you know
maybe somebody's gonna trade in front of
us at number six
and take him with the dolphins who are
always open for business so
that was probably a nerve-wracking hour
for the lions while they waited for
sewell to slide and it would explain
you don't give up more to get him you
stay put
he falls to you and it's party time in
detroit
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports